i do
find it kind of interesting uh it is nft
based but
uh i don't think it has to be this
uh this idea of i think big clout it's
called
or whatever the idea of sort of
investing in individuals
it makes me immediately think about
investing in
ideas so even just the words you speak
having value and sort of
if you have a frictionless like
automated
financial system then you could do a
bunch of interesting things about
what it means to add value to the world
i mean
i don't know if bitcloud is currently an
efficient representation of that
but i am truly happy
that however that thing works
i am just one notch above vladimir putin
which is one of the that's like one of
the bucket list items for me
to have a list where i'm one notch above
putin well
what i think you're talking about here
is important because there's
uh historical examples you could invest
in
a patent in some situations you could
invest in
an organization that has an idea right
so these are
super inefficient given kind of the the
vision that you're painting in terms of
like investing directly in an idea in a
super efficient automated fashion
but that's how the technology evolution
works right is
it's really hard to do it first and then
slowly kind of becomes easier and easier
as technology
uh is more prevalent the other thing
that i think is interesting is this
whole idea of investing in people
if you really think about the
origination of that as i would hire
somebody
right right i pay you money and then
you're going to create production
but i take the lion's share and you
don't now there's things like
these isas these income sharing
agreements where basically i will
educate you on something train you on
something i'll put up capital
right and then over time you'll pay me
back plus profits
as some version eventually i don't know
what it looks like
but being able to get upside in
somebody's success
for having risk capital early on doesn't
seem that far off
seen in professional sports you see it
in you know a lot of these things and so
i just think that a lot of um the focus
right now
is on the technology but ultimately
these are
ideas that are very old and have had
lots of success and traction
and we're just merely standing in the
way of the evolution of these ideas
with new technology and so it's easy to
get caught up in the technology but when
you really zoom out and look at it from
the
ideological standpoint and kind of the
progress of humanity
it's a foregone conclusion this stuff's
going to happen it's just how
i think the world is waiting and some of
us are trying to create
that future world which is like what are
the applications of this technology that
will transform the world
and then you know i hate the term but
killer apps like
cool ideas that are implemented
effectively at scale to transform the
world there's been
there's been a lot of different ideas
popping up
like the there's a lot of ideas about
social networks that are built on top of
the technology and all that kind of
stuff
you